we gotta do what we do is an inner
production studio right now so we gotta
do some acapella stuff alright cool we
can do that you know I would whoever
wants to go first yo I look um how fly
is a [__] like I hit the sky so far but
I figure I try to find out where the
cloud tastes like scrumptious with these
[__] rhyme sound like buckets try to
talk to women like I'm Frederick
Douglass but they just want me to take
him to Frederick's on Douglas she don't
want the sky she just went to skype she
don't want to see the light she just
want to be in lights in the world keep
turning feeling like EPMD I need a
sermon cuz life be a crock of like Steve
Irwin crikey swoosh by like I bought
stock in nike I stay in the studio cuz I
know that life be like that hair on
yugioh wild and spiky that's Rob me I'd
be high up in the sky g you just gotta
reach a little higher just like me I'm
almost a reaching up like I need a hand
convincing the pilot that we don't even
need to land tell them [__] get low
me saying people don't want to grow like
Peter Pan fan of the Pixies but you're
windy I don't use the dust I just think
happy thoughts in the flu me up left
Neverland and groom me up got the net
hooked a pirate in my music but it blew
me up boom busy in the room feeling like
that MF ER and i don't mean Joan on top
of my cake like a figure rain grown
wanna jump up to the sky for what jump
over the broom zone hmm I'm gone
inebriated Italy like I love you
abbreviate it got stripes in the streets
i rated all over my jacket like a zebra
mated 1-day to sell here the greatest
yeah one day they'll say he the greatest
cars where were ya I think that we in
Vegas bootleg cab where we gonna take it
double accelerate it the sauce made it
yeah busy ah something goes like I wanna
see Phil then it's written out on the
check in the amount of 1 million until
then I'm [__] bleed just like us
showing when you come from Queens
leaving [__] done son check it y'all
belong in the wastepaper basket me i
chase paper to the cast it so the number
one question they were asking your
courses are really that drastic of
course it is for that paper and plastic
me back for Broadway and even at Aston
more and music my heart's not confused
with the Peter Paul of Judah says I
don't care who it is who beat out
calling DDOT corner but the beat of mad
rapper with DDOT calling the kind of
trap I ain't falling for so telling
Peter Parker's in the Clark Kent's I had
my homie having slap on some dark
intense but that ain't enough for the
bounty hunter who listened to his lost
tapes and founders hunger and realized
if you want to win a crown by summer you
better show the fan the troof about
these [__] cuz they deserve
answers instead of backstabs since i'm
done with that logo like the gap bag and
about broma when I love jabs but you
ain't gonna have me like ham on a
punching bag now I throw hey make us at
you clay Aikens cuz for my eggs and
bacon I [__] harder than cinnamon with a
leg shaking whoa young holy [__] yo he
said something earlier I feel like he
just proved its cons yo